hey everybody I'm Dave Karger from
Fandango very happy to be joined by the
Backstreet Boys Brian Littrell Kevin
Richardson Nick Carter Howie Dorough AJ
McLean the stars of the new documentary
Backstreet Boys Sean which are made of
were the biggest band in the world
nobody thought it was gonna be as big as
it was it's in theaters it's on iTunes
for everyone to check out you know I
always get very nostalgic when I see you
guys because the first time I ever
interviewed you was for this 18 years
ago so if you were to each look at
yourself in this picture what's the one
word you would use to describe yourself
at this young sexy Tony Stark Tony Stark
Wahlberg Kevin dark how he had wopo nice
like three musketeers you guys the movie
is very emotional this is where the old
bastard lived yeah Portland prison now
he's you know what for bio six or
whatever they have in jail there's a lot
of crying in this document a pansy who
cries the most Kevin hands down but Nick
your cry is like the biggest I don't
like to cry we've seen the best and the
worst of each other
afraid of you anymore I hate crying I
like always have a problem I gotta go
therapy please cried down but he's got
the whole mix yeah so this came out and
it just came out triggered floodgates
you've accomplished so much in 20 years
what's something that you haven't done
that you'd like to do still receive a
Grammy get it like to be a Grammy Award
would be nice there's not a several
times where somebody like Santana or
Santana okay before I go it's time to
play games
I want to see how well you guys know
your own history so I have a bunch of
trivia questions you shout out what you
think the answer is the only rule is if
you shout out an answer and it's wrong
you have to let everybody else try
before you shout out a second answer so
here we go
in 2001 you perform the national anthem
at the Super Bowl what city was it in it
was my birthday how I get that to Brian
and you win a pair of Fandango movie
tickets why each correct answer on the
movie but I didn't take it in what
country did you earn your first German
it was Brian nice I can see the lips it
was close how you guys have had one
number one song in Australia what was it
playing games no no you can't answer
yeah no as long as you love me
incomplete Nick Carter for the win ok
you want an MTV Movie Award for your
appearance in this is the end
what was the category called best dance
performance no musical performance ago
best musical musical moment right let's
roll further win in 2000 your music was
nominated for five Grammys how many of
those five did you lose to Santana or
Brian Littrell
oh I was gonna say it speaking of Fort
I'm thinking for guests to think for
time sir Brian's going tonight after
great to see you everybody did you find
out this documentary it's really
fascinating great job ok I'm gonna care
he's going to the movie